wrapper juice world has died at the age
of 21 real name Jared Anthony Higgins
the musician died early Sunday morning
after suffering a quote medical
emergency at Chicago's Midway Airport
where he was reportedly rushed to the
hospital and pronounced dead the Chicago
Police Department tells et that juice
world quote suffered what appears to be
some type of medical emergency according
to the people traveling with him adding
there were no signs of foul play and all
individuals aboard the aircraft are
cooperating with CPD and have given all
of their information a representative
from the department added that they're
currently awaiting the Cook County
medical examiner for the cause and
manner of death the singers record label
released a statement quote he was a
gentle soul whose creativity knew no
bounds an exceptional human being an
artist who loved and cared for his fans
above everything else to lose someone so
kind and so close to our hearts is
devastating juice world released two
studio albums throughout his career many
of his fans are now taking notice of one
of his tracks from 2018 called legends
which features a lyric referencing the
27 club a term that originated after
multiple artists from Amy Winehouse to
Jim Morrison died at 27 years old
[Music]
juice world's death at that age has
added an eerie layer to the tragedy the
music industry immediately began sending
out tributes for the rapper on social
media fellow Chicago born artist chance
the rapper posted on Instagram quote
millions of people not just in Chicago
but around the world are hurting because
of this and don't know what to make of
it I'm sorry love you and God bless your
soul hashtag legend Meek Mill wrote
quote this is unbelievable and on
Twitter Ellie Goulding posted a photo
with the late singer juice world's death
was also followed by tributes from Drake
Camilla Kibeho Zane Lowe Austin Mahone
and LL Cool J who simply wrote hashtag
rested power juice world
[Music]